(upbeat piano music)
- We don't have to clean.
- What do you wanna do
with all our extra time?
- We could make some
cold-pressed organic juices.
- We could switch over
to paperless billing.
- We could floss our teeth.
- We could find out who my father is.
Oh, my god.
(cat wails)
- Oh, holy shit.
- There's cat shit in the vacuum.
(upbeat lounge music)
- The thing looks sick, what does it do?
- [Robot] I can check email, brew coffee,
kill spiders, do therapy sessions,
I can even dance.
(group exclaims)
(intense rap beat)
- [Group] Go Gino, go Gino, go Gino
- Great point, Gino.
I feel like you are the only one here
who really understands me.
- You know, your robot
can't make out with you.
- [Robot] I don't want him for his body.
I like him for his mind.
(upbeat lounge music)
(phone ringing)
- No, no, no, no, no.
I just got a notification
that the milk's expired.
- Oh my God, that could
have been really bad.
- Shhh, come here.
You're safe now.
- Checking stats?
How's Denver doing?
- Oh, no I'm checking out the milk stats.
The smart jug tells me all kinds
of vital stuff about the milk.
Expiration date, temperature,
what farm the milk came
from, what percentage,
cause you've got your
skim milk, you got 2%.
Yeah, just basically milk stuff.
(upbeat lounge music)
(phone ringing)
- Oh, babe, don't answer it.
It's gonna let all the heat out.
- Babe, chillax, no inconvenience,
I've got my bluetooth glove.
Hello?
(phone buzzing)
Hello? Hello?
(upbeat lounge music)
- Aren't these USB slippers better
than warming your icy toes
on my extremely athletic calves?
Alright, what are we watching?
- Oh, let me run to the bathroom first.
- No, wait, oh!
(soothing lounge music)
- Oh, the blinds. I'll get em.
- No, no, no, no no,
Those feet are too adorbs
to walk another step.
Here.
(mechanical whirr)
(constant mechanical whirr)
- [Woman] Nooo.
(upbeat lounge music)
- Oh, Cindy Crawford,
you are the flyest cat.
And it's all thanks to your
smart feeder, isn't it?
You get the right portions every time.
Yeah, that's where your food comes from.
- [Woman] So much for portion control.
- [Man] Cindy Crawford, you (beep).